[Music]
[Music]
when i'm asleep
my brain is still emotion
i sort of see it like little pieces of
fiber that are connecting
it's incredible how active my mind is
when i'm
supposed to be laying asleep when i'm
asleep my brain is
active and going around
when i'm awake in the day my brain is
like this
when i go to sleep at night my brain is
like this
just waking up awake
and sleeping kind of tapers off to this
just waking up point again
when you're asleep you're pretty much
awake
but you don't know it
when i'm asleep i think my cells are
resting
your brain needs time to recover and
rest and let
synapses heal i think the stress is just
too great for us nowadays if we don't
get a minimum of seven hours sleep
we're in serious trouble my body needs
rest it needs to take off its job it
does a lot
sometimes i'm willing to face things
when i'm asleep that i might not really
want to
deal with when i'm awake maybe sort of a
kind of a sexual dream if you will with
maybe someone it shouldn't be with
maybe i'm attracted to somebody and in
my dreams i'm really flirtatious
then if i come across this person again
i think i'll flirt a little bit more
my dreams sometimes
are just like maybe scenes from stuff
i watch you know like star wars or
batman the animated series
and so i'm seeing like scenes from and
it's like
scene after scene after scene like
i was sort of driving around in a small
clown car for some reason
talking to albert einstein newton and i
remember specifically them telling me
that two plus two did not equal four i'm
falling through like an
endless hole and i actually feel
like if i'm actually falling
well that's a good question where does
my mind go i don't really know
mine is searching for solutions can't be
on all the time
my mind's awake but i'm sleeping
i don't know about dreams i think it's
important maybe it's not that important
sleep and dreams are such an insight
into yourself
and your own challenges amazing
hello i'm carl zimmer
thank you all for coming out for this
evening of an exploration of sleep
i'm sure that all of you like myself
have asked a lot of those questions that
we just saw
and actually tonight we're going to be
able to talk with
three of the world's experts on sleep
people who study sleep for a living
and in three really remarkably different
ways we're going to learn
about how animals sleep how does a bird
sleep
exactly we're going to eavesdrop on a
rat stream
and we're also going to watch what
happens when human sleep
goes really really wrong so without
further ado
i'd like to introduce our guest our
speakers um
the first one is dr niels rattenberg
dr rattenberg has made groundbreaking
discoveries
dr rattenberg's made groundbreaking
discoveries uh on the animal sleep
including birds
he's at the max planck institute for
ornithology in germany
he's taken a red eye to join us but he
seems to be absolutely awake
uh our next uh panelist will be dr
matthew wilson
uh dr wilson is a neuroscientist at mit
and a researcher at the pick hour
institute for learning
and memory where he has the particular
expertise of eavesdropping on rat dreams
and our final panelist will be dr carlos
shank
dr shank is a renowned sleep clinician
he's a psychiatrist and he's a
researcher at the minnesota regional
sleep
disorder center where he specializes on
bizarre sleep
behavior so let's have a round of
applause for our panelists
uh and i'd also like to say hello to
everyone who's watching on the live
stream
uh you're you're in the audience here
you're you're
uh part of a much bigger group and we
welcome you all
um so niels i thought we could start by
talking
to you about human sleep
and animal sleep and i believe you
brought a really nice
picture of a human and a coral to kind
of put this into context if we could
have that picture
so here we have two animals uh
the human us and the coral um maybe you
could tell us a bit about
sleep in the animal kingdom i mean uh we
all have seen
our dogs or cats sleep but i mean how
widespread is sleep
among animals yeah well one approach to
understanding the purpose of
sleep in our brain and sleep in general
is to look at how different types of
animals sleep
do all animals sleep the same way are
there some animals that don't sleep
and by studying animals ranging from
simple organisms such as
this brain coral to more complex
organisms we may gain insight into the
function of sleep both in general and in
our brain
so does a coral sleep well they
retreat into their uh calcium house
in in the daytime so these corals might
actually be sleeping while the
awake i presume awake human is uh
observing them
right flies there's a lot of work
studying
fruit flies in the last 10 years and
they've
been shown to clearly engage in sleep
they have many
parallels with sleep in
humans sleep in in mammals uh they
uh their sleep becomes more fragmented
when they get older
there are changes in in the brain uh
chemistry
and expression of genes that are very
similar to those in
in humans and this is proven to be a
very powerful
organism in which to try to gain insight
into the function of sleep
because in the fruit fly you can
manipulate the genome you can turn genes
on you can turn genes off you can induce
mutations and look at how that affects
their sleep
and if you find some gene that's very
interesting
that affects their sleep then you can
look in mammals to see if it plays a
similar role
and that can give us clues to the
purpose of sleep
now you study a much closer relative to
us than
brain coral you you study birds
um how did you get interested in
studying birds and and
why do you think they're important for
helping us to understand sleep in
general
yeah i actually worked first with humans
and then went to study birds and birds
are an extremely
exciting group in which to study sleep
because they're the only taxonomic group
that has evolved
sleep patterns very much like ours and
those observed in the rest of the
mammals why don't you tell us about what
our sleep are basically parent is and
then
talk about how birds are like that yeah
so in humans and other
mammals we engage in two general types
of sleep and these are
measured by looking at changes in brain
activity in the sleeping
human there is a rem sleep or rapid eye
movement sleep
during this state the the brain actually
is exhibiting a
pattern of activity that's very similar
to that observed when we're awake
but we're unresponsive we're clearly
asleep
then there's another state called
non-rem sleep
which the brain waves are are markedly
different
and when you look at the brainwave
activity of a bird that's sleeping
they do the same thing they exhibit both
these states
they have rem sleep their eyes start
around their brain is very activated
very much like when they're awake
they lose some muscle tone just like we
do
maybe if you have a a cat
sometimes if they sleep on top of a
television
when they enter rem sleep they lose
muscle tone and they roll off the tv and
fall on the floor
that's one way to see this at home
try it out try it at home yes
and if you have uh dogs will often
move their paws and whimper as as if
chasing rabbits and they're
they're in rem sleep but so these two
sleep states that we have birds have
them also
and they don't have similar sleep states
because they share a common ancestor
that had the same sleep states
they seem to have evolved these patterns
independently
so so mammal get the ram non-rem sleep
birds get it too yeah so the closest
living relatives to birds are
the crocodiles and other reptiles and
they don't show these
two distinct states they clearly see
crocodiles probably don't dream
at least i don't know we'll find out
but um so and now
you found one really amazing difference
between
us and birds which is i mean when we go
to sleep
the lights are all out in the sense that
our whole brain is involved in sleep
whereas with birds it's not always the
case right
yeah birds can do a very interesting
thing
and that is they can sleep with one eye
open
this had been observed uh decades ago
um but nobody had really addressed what
was the function of
sleeping with one eye open now this
might seem like a obvious question and
the obvious answer would be that they're
watching
for something dangerous while sleeping
you can imagine that sleeping is
a very dangerous state to engage in
especially if you live with predators
and so we were interested in testing
whether
birds use this to watch for predators
and maybe i can just back up one second
and
talk about the image that's currently on
the screen
for many animals there really is this
fundamental conflict between the need to
be
awake and also the need to get their
sleep
an interest in this conflict dates back
thousands of years
as shown in the legend depicted in this
piece of art according to this legend
in order to stay safe while sleeping one
crane in a group would stay awake
holding a stone
and if he started to fall asleep he
would relax and drop the stone
and thereby awaken everybody um
and that's how they were thought to keep
themselves safe
now there's absolutely no scientific
evidence that the
cranes do this but as i was
discussing birds can sleep with one eye
open and when they have one
eye open the half of the brain connected
to that eye is
is kind of in a awake or slightly drowsy
state
and so we were interested in learning
whether
they can actually choose when to sleep
this way
or when to sleep with both eyes closed
because they don't
sleep only this way they spend a lot of
time sleeping with both eyes closed
and so what we wanted to do was find a
way to make
them feel a little nervous when they
were sleeping just a little edgy
a little edgy um and so
we thought about various ways you know
show them a cat or
or something but uh
and while we were trying to figure out
how to test this uh
i was observing some of our ducks that
we were studying in the laboratory
and i saw that two of them at night were
floating in the water next to each other
and while they were doing that they were
closing the eye
that faced each other and opening the
eye that was
facing out from each other and that
right then and there the birds designed
the experiment for us
people often say oh that's such an
elegant study and i have to say well
it came from a bird brand so did you
acknowledge the ducks in your paper
so um so this is this is the experiment
uh kind of the opera
the way yeah the upper image shows the
actual
experimental apparatus and so what we
did is we
literally put our ducts in a row and
we did this because it's been shown in
many animals that the animals at the
edge of a group
spend more time being vigilant like
antelope and
africa if they're at the edge of the
group they lift their head up and
interrupt their feeding more frequently
than the ones in the center
presumably the ones at the edge feel
more exposed and more at risk of being
eaten because
the predator would get them first so we
put our ducks in a row
and what we found was a very dramatic
effect
of where they were in the group the
birds that
were in the more central positions that
were flanked by ducks on either side
they spent most of their time sleeping
with both eyes closed and both halves of
their brain
but when the birds were positioned at
the end of the row
they switched and they spent much more
time sleeping with one eye open
and they showed a profound preference
for directing that
open eye away from the other birds as
shown in the cartoon at the bottom
so this clearly showed that they have
this capacity
to sleep with one eye open and that it
serves a function in allowing them to
get some sleep without getting eaten
and um i believe we have an image of a
seal as well
if we could show that because this is so
this isn't just limited to birds i mean
so so
there are other situations where animals
will switch off
yeah it this seems to be a common trait
among
birds but among mammals this type of
sleep is only found in marine mammals
it's found in in the cetaceans the
dolphins and whales
in some of the seals like the fur seal
shown in this image
and also in manatees
and in the case of this image it's a fur
seal
and what they do is the they have the
awake
half of their brain in this case the
right half
that's attached to the flipper down in
the water and that flipper paddles and
keeps them in a position that allows
them to keep their nose above the
surface
and that way they can sleep and breathe
at the same time
and this uh needing to sleep in and
breathe
is seems to be probably what's driving
the evil
or drove the evolution of this type of
sleep in
in marine mammals and so we mammals can
afford
we sort of land mammals can afford to
sleep with our whole brains
yeah it's it seems that there there must
be some
trade-off uh for being able to sleep
this way otherwise i
i would expect it to be much more common
in the animal
uh among mammals but it seems to be
restricted to these
mammals living in a marine environment
however there is
evidence even in humans that sleep can
be a local phenomena in the brain
although we're behaviorally we're fully
asleep
uh parts of the brain can sleep more
deeply than other parts at the same time
and a lot of our current uh thoughts
about the function of sleep
and uh based on this local aspect of
sleep we're derived from these studies
with the marine mammals
and uh this modulation of sleep
intensity
locally in the brain seems to be related
to how we use
certain parts of the brain during
wakefulness so
so a region we might be using a lot
might
go into a deep sleep when we're asleep
yeah so um if
somebody did a certain task with their
hand
that part of the brain connected to that
will sleep more deeply
afterwards and you can even do the
opposite
and there are studies showing that if
you immobilize an arm
for a day then the part of the brain
that controls that arm
shows lighter sleep that night so we're
clearly
getting something out of sleep um and in
a way
some of the demands in our waking life
make us need to get more of it for those
particular areas so there's something
about sleep
is it uh you know restoring our energy i
mean
why would a coral or a fly need to sleep
you know like we do too i mean what is
what's the currency there that we all
want
yeah it's a great question i think um
one thing is to keep in mind is that
sleep may have had an
initial primordial function
perhaps in these coral or other simple
organisms
but that once an animal was sleeping
and as they became more complex other
functions may
accumulated during the course of
evolution so
sleep in humans and sleeping birds may
not be the same
as in these animals but i think
to get back to birds i have a bird bias
i kind of like them but
um that's okay here um
this fact that they independently evolve
similar sleep states it really is an
opportunity to understand the function
of these states
if we can figure out what it is that a
bird brain has in common
with a human brain that should give us
clues to what
the function of these states are so
clearly
we have a lot of mysteries still left to
figure out
even about human sleep we
actually talked to one of the real
pioneers of modern sleep research
robert stickled of harvard medical
school
and posed a few questions to him about
sleep
and we're going to show you a video of
some of his provocative answers
there seem to be limits to the
resolution of our dreams so if i ask you
to picture
um a little german shepherd next to a
great big elephant
it turns out that if i want to ask you
to describe the dog's
ears you have to zoom in on your mind
because you don't have the resolution to
see it so it might be
that you just don't have enough
resolution on your
imaginal screen on your mental image
to see small letters you can read large
letters going by
but try to close your eyes and picture
the phrase
i'm doing fine how are you you sort of
can't squeeze it into your mental image
everybody seems to think that their
dreams
have great meaning and that's what makes
us
so much want to share them i think
what's going on when we're dreaming
is that the brain as opposed to the mind
is going through the events of our days
and recalling memories and
trying to find associated memories from
other times in our life that might be
relevant
so if the brain is looking for ways to
put things together
you want its bias to be shifted towards
oh that's really interesting so when you
wake up
the conscious equivalent of that bias
shift towards towards value
is to say wow that was so meaningful
that's why
your husband and my wife wakes up and
said oh i had the most
amazing dream and i say that's nice
but what was the great insight but to
them and to me when i wake up
they seem incredibly meaningful
so matt i i wanted to ask you
i mean where do we stand now with dream
research i mean
there have been so many ideas over the
years you've had freud with his ideas
and other people who say oh that's wrong
dreams are completely random and
meaningless
what are dreams well you know i think
that the kind of work that i do
involves not the study of human dreams
but of animal dreams and you might ask
animal dreams what does that mean i mean
how do you how can you tell when an
animal is dreaming
you can't wake them up and you know give
them a dream notebook or ask them what
they dreamed
you know what they dreamt about you can
but they won't really answer
so you can how could you actually
stuttle study animal dreams
and the answer is to bypass the
mechanisms of dream report
go directly to the source and that is to
record the activity
of brain cells while animals are awake
and having experience
and then record the activity of the same
cells while animals are sleeping
and ask essentially compare the patterns
do the patterns that we see when animals
are moving through the world experience
in the world
in the world do they reappear in some
form
during sleep so it's a direct measure of
both the structure of brain activity and
you know neil's mentioned that there are
these those sleep states
in which the structure of activity seems
to be very different that's how we
define these sleep states
deep sleep with these slow oscillations
much of the brain seems to you know
to be moving in lockstep which is
distinct from
wakefulness when many parts of the brain
are being driven
based upon what you're doing what you're
seeing in other words
the brain when you're awake is
responding to the external world
the brain during sleep seems to be
responding to some internal world so how
can we get at this
internal world you mentioned freud and
the idea that maybe we have
you know different levels layers
different types
of brain activity that correspond to
different kinds of cognition that there
is
the conscious the unconscious those uh
the
you know the deep hidden parts of the
brain
that that might influence behavior but
we can't really
articulate we can't talk about they
that they're available to us but
how would we actually measure them so
again the strategy is
using an animal model that has it
actually as its
benefit the inability to tell us or to
report
what they're dreaming so they're
requiring the rats don't wake up in the
morning and say you would not
believe that
and if they could you know the way we
would interpret that is
that well that might be what you thought
you dreamt about
but i want to know what you actually
dreamt about and so again it would be
going directly to the source
so putting very fine electrodes into the
brains
of animals and in particular we focus on
a part of the brain that's involved in
memory
so you would think well i thought we
were talking about dreams isn't dreams
about
perception what we experience the uh you
know and
uh just a little segue there we you know
we talked about dreaming we talk about
dream sleep
and neil mentioned you know rem and
non-rem sleep
and there's this misconception that
dream sleep
is really associated with rem sleep so
rem sleep is with the rapid eye movement
that's when you see the dogs and you
know other fictive movements
and clearly there is dreaming that goes
on there and you know i'll discuss a
little bit about
those kinds of dreams but there is also
dream activity we can call it dream-like
activity
during non-rem sleep and that is the
kind of sleep
that would be expressed
not just birds mammals but
in flies and potentially every organism
would have this kind of inactive sleep
non-rem sleep
which again i'll point out stairs so
you're saying flies dream too
they could dream too that dreaming is
actually
not it's not the province of a spec of a
specific dream state
it may be something that actually
emerged
after the brain found some usefulness
in becoming inactive so what happens
when
you kind of shut down you no longer
attend to the external world
the brain isn't going to turn off the
brain never turns off
if the brain has turned off you're
either under the influence of an
anesthetic
that has intentionally suppressed brain
activity or
you're in a coma you are you know in a
sense
in a state that is unnatural so
anesthesia is more like a coma than
being asleep so when you sleep your
brain is very active it's not shut off
in any way as you saw in you know some
of the subjective descriptions that you
know the kids they're talking about
you know uh uh their brains during sleep
very active and it's true it is very
active but it's active in a very
different way maybe we could show
uh some of matt's experiments next
because
um they're just really amazing right so
we're right
so we'll jump into it yeah and just as a
little prelude here so the idea before
we started why don't you set it up for
us right
so here we are so you can imagine you're
sitting right now in the lab
because this is exactly what we would
see if we were sitting in the lab and on
the right-hand side
uh you see a top down it's a video of
what we call a maze it's a long
track it's like a long hallway it's
about 10 meters long actually pretty
long for this rat it would take this rat
maybe you know maybe a minute or two
actually to you know to fully go back
and forth along this
on the left what you're seeing is brain
activity
those little flashing lights each time
you see a little flash that is the
discharge of a single brain cell
and the little colored regions indicate
different brain cells so what you're
seeing is
in real time what in this case 2 4 6 8
9 eight or nine individual brain cells
are doing
and we'll loop through this again could
you loop through that one again for us
the same one what these brain cells are
doing when an animal's
running on this little track now in this
part of the brain this memory part of
the brain called the hippocampus
one striking thing that we see is that
the pattern that you see
on the left is going to depend upon
exactly where the animal is on the right
in other words there's a correspondence
between
what the brain is doing and where the
animal is
when the animal is moving so you can see
that on the right the little
the the little dots or the
uh you know the brain activity the
single discharge of single cells
is mapped onto the maze so for instance
you see in the lower left
there are lots of blue points that's
because the blue cell
it's not really blue it's just color
coded that way the blue cell
tends to fire whenever the animal's in
that part of the maze
on the other hand you see the little
cyan cell down in the lower right
and and we have places i should say we
have place else too so if like i was
walking through my house
you know exactly a place that would fire
as i went past the counter in my kitchen
so you could
so you could say well you know if i'm in
there if i could record the activity
these cells
memory cells are cells that fire in
certain places if i could record them i
might be able to tell just by
reading your mind in a sense where you
where you are
well so if we go to the next video the
next video so let's just try that or you
read the mind of a rat
so now it's going to be the same
experiment the same data
you can see on the left that's it's the
same brain cells firing away
but on the right now instead of showing
you where the brain cells fire when the
animal's on the maze instead
we're decoding the activity we're
guessing
where the animal is just by looking at
what's going on in the brain
now if you watch when the animal starts
walking along the track see the little
triangles there
that's our best guess as to where the
animal is
and it does pretty well the green circle
is just there to kind of show you
uh where the rat is so our guess the
triangles
fall right on top of the circle where
the animal is
but notice when the animal stops and
maybe we can just rewind
well you can actually see here animal
stop and we'll
rewind it animal moving brain tells
the brain tells you where the animal is
animal stops
notice where the triangles go they stop
firing they or they stop
reflecting where the animal is you see
them you see that little flash
the triangles jumped across the track it
was just a fraction of a second
very brief but the brain activity during
those brief moments
instead reflects not where the animal is
but where it has been or where it could
be
the animal is thinking about in a sense
things that are remote from its
immediate experience
time travel yeah time travel animal just
you know it's
sitting briefly and what happens in this
part of the brain it's an older part of
the brain the paleocortex which includes
these
these brain areas that are critical for
memory for emotion
for driving uh what you might think of
as a more
primitive behavior well this part of the
brain
can shut off on a dime in just a
fraction of a second it can go from
being actively engaged taking
information in from the outside world
to going into what looks remarkably like
sleep so these memory and emotional
areas can go to sleep while
the newer parts of the brain the
neocortex the part of the brain that's
important for keeping track of
you know threats of monitoring the
external world of making sure you get to
where you're going
the part of the brain that has to deal
with the outside world
that can be awake and this other part of
the brain can be asleep so we can think
of
this state of just thinking would you
call it attentive which is called
what you call daydreaming almost now
daydreaming might be if i you know if
you're sitting there and you say ah you
know
wilson is not really interesting anymore
i'm gonna
you know i wonder what you know where do
i park my car now you start your mind
starts to wander
you start thinking about this your the
memory parts of the brain
that can now go back and retrieve past
experience they got more interesting
you've got that parking lot play cell
firing it's there
but now the longer you remain in that
state
the further out the more you can
actually think about
remote from where you are right now and
if you stay in that stay long you say
daydreaming
at some point you may actually start to
drift off into
sleep you may make a transition from
this quiet wakefulness
into early non-rem sleep so you can
think of non-rem sleep
as emerging in a sense from what the
brain naturally does
when it doesn't have to you know it
doesn't have to attend to the outside
world
that might only last a fraction of a
second it might last
20 minutes it might last 20 hours
it's it looks
remarkably similar from the perspective
of these
parts of the brain involved in memory so
somehow these memory areas are trying to
take advantage of this
offline state and if we can just switch
to the third video
you can see this this is going to be the
same basic it's the same
experiment you can see the activity of
these brain cells on the left
but now the animal is not running on the
maze anymore
he's not stopped on the maze anymore in
the lower right
that little circle that you see there
that's actually a rat curled up they
they kind of sleep in this little curled
up posture
there's a rat he's sleeping he's off now
another part of the you know another
part of the room sleeping
but these memory cells place cells
are replaying his experience on the maze
they're running through they're running
through interestingly
these little sequences short stretches
it's like a little snippet a fragment of
its experience
along the maze but notice a couple of
things one is
they're very fast and one thing about
these
replayed memories during quiet
wakefulness and during non-rem sleep
is they seem to be compressed in time
they run about 10 times
faster than the animal's actual
experience
and also if you look very carefully
notice the direction of that triangle
the direction of the triangle indicates
that's the direction the animal would be
facing in while i was moving on the
track
well some of those little memory
sequences
run in reverse they go backward in time
so it's as though during while
wakefulness and during non-rem sleep the
brain has the ability to go back
revisit past memories to revisit these
memories in a
compressed form and it's got a rewind
button it can go forward or backward
so you could ask why would you you know
why would you want to
revisit memories in this peculiar form
you'd get rid of time you compress it
and you run it forward and backward
well if you think about what's going on
during these states
it's not just replaying memory but
trying to do something
that we think is probably more
fundamental and important to the animals
and that is to learn from experience how
would you learn
from your experience how would you go
back reevaluate maybe compare different
things as bob stickle had mentioned
in his little piece compare different
experiences
and to try to figure out the the
fundamental challenge
that we as organisms and these brains
face and that is
how does this world work what are the
rules of the world because i'm going to
have to tomorrow
i'm going to have to go out into that
world
encounter new things things that i
haven't actually experienced and i'm
going to have to make
good decisions i'm going to have to
produce adaptive behavior
under novel circumstances and that's
what we can do
and robots can't do they're great when
you tell them exactly what to do and
when they know
exactly you know what uh what should be
done
you give them anything new and they
simply
can't make those critical judgments so
do we need to
program robots so they can dream well
the question is what would they
what would they do if they were dreaming
so clearly they would the first step
would be
let's go back first form memories
memories of experience where we keep
track of a couple of things
one is we keep track of the order of
events
as they occurred because that's very
important order of that's very important
you know you're at a stoplight light
turns green
you go all right that's now
you know and so in your dreams you might
have this little sequence light goes
green
cars move now you might extend that
there might be a longer sequence okay
the light turns green
if you don't go people start honking
okay so this is now in your dreams you
might be imagining
but now that might be a simple rule that
we would have to learn
but one thing that's very important
about these simple rules is
one rule doesn't necessarily fit all
circumstances
they might be dependent on the context
context is just
you know it might be where you are it
might be the time of day it's just
it's all of these additional things that
might change the nature of the rule so
for instance
that rule that i gave you light turns
green if you don't go you start honking
okay
that's the general rule it's the kind of
rule that you know
i might have learned growing up in a
small town in northeastern wisconsin
that rule applies now i come to new york
it was a little bit different
it's cars you start honking
then the light turns green and so i
learned that right
different rules different context now
the question is well how do you you know
how do you tell a robot how to do that
well the robot has to both have
experiences in both it has to be able to
remember and you know and be able to
express
the time ordering of events figuring out
how things actually happen
and then it has to do something that
i think is unique it's unique perhaps to
organisms
that have exploited sleep and that's be
able to figure out
what the what the significance is of
this context
are there really different rules for
different places should i combine these
should i figure out one rule or are
there really two rules well wait a
minute
the thing is that you make dreams sound
so practical and so reasonable
in my dreams there are cactuses that
turn into monsters
and i mean just it's my dreams are crazy
so
well right well so this is again so
we're back to this misconception in new
york cactuses do not turn into monsters
and that's because what you're what
you're describing to me is almost
certainly a dream that you experience
during rem
ah so and then round and round now
so i didn't illustrate a rendering but
when we do the same experiment
we measure brain activity during rem it
looks very different
and one of the key differences is
there are memories that are replayed but
they're not compressed in time they
don't come in these small
these small little fragments but rather
they're played out
in real time as though the animal is
actually experiencing these events
that there are other that one can tell
neil pointed out that you know when
you're awake when you're asleep
there are you know very different brain
states
and you can tell when an animal is awake
by just looking at the way the brain
responds there are these oscillations
rhythms that kick in
there are certain rhythms that uh that
correspond to being attentive
to moving in the world other rhythms
that correspond to being inattentive
well during realm the rhythms are the
rhythms that you would get
if you were attending if you were moving
through the world during rem
as far as the brain is concerned it's
awake
it just doesn't happen to be moving and
it's in
the rem state where now you see it's
the animals are dreaming about things as
though they were actually happening
now you know another point about this
the non-rem so we go back to the non-rem
we think of it's more primitive perhaps
a process of taking memory and
experience
trying to learn from it maybe taking
different experiences
comparing them determining whether maybe
there is this one rule maybe it is
you know light green you know you better
you better go
or cars will start honking maybe that's
the rule and
everywhere i've gone that's the rule but
now i come to new york and somehow
things are screwed up why are they
honking the light has not turned green
yet
there's something wrong maybe it's a
context difference maybe you have to
figure out
what it is about new york city
that might that might you know uh
require that i form a special rule a
context dependent rule
and another thing about the hippocampus
the part of the brain i was talking
about the
you know that's involved in memory
that's replaying these things during
sleep
and that is that it is critically uh uh
involved in recognizing context just
knowing where you are being able to
figure out oh
yeah i'm you know at my home why because
when i put all the pieces together what
i see what i hear where i came from
i know where i am and so you can think
about that as
something that's very fundamental
knowing where you are
that may be sort of the anchor for
context different rules in different
places
so we have rem you know you're running
through these
longer sequences of the actual
experience in non-rem
you have these little fragments and when
we look at the fragments
in non-rem they seem to relate to pretty
much what the animal was just doing
they're more mundane it's the animal
keeps running through the maze over and
over and so a little fragment that you
saw
during non-rem sleep it's mostly slow
waves slow wave sleep it's the slow
rhythm goes on about we know once a
second
brain is turning on and off meals point
out different parts of the brain
might you know might show stronger
rhythms
as you pointed out parts of the brain
that you have really been using
if you were you know uh if you're doing
something during the day and you look
during sleep those parts of the brain
maybe the visual parts of the brain if
you're involved in
some visual processing might be going up
and down
you know more vigorously well it's in
those little fragments
the little fragment that lasts about a
second
that's where you see these small
memories being these
compressed memory fragments being
expressed now what's important about
that
is it says a that our experience
can be broken up into little chunks you
can think of memory
as actually being a series of building
blocks that are experienced
i kind of think of it like you know
memories like a big bag of
lego blocks you know where each one of
our experiences
can be built out of a series of these
blocks
now unlike lego blocks which i can take
and i can
put together in virtually any way these
memory lego blocks
can only be matched with other blocks in
which the peg and the slot
they you know they correspond in
somewhere they can be associated maybe
they're linked by a common emotion
maybe you know uh it's a it's a
it's a common location it's a common cue
so putting together a building
a model of the world out of these memory
blocks requires a little bit of tension
you have to go in
take these little pieces maybe you try
you know one piece after maybe you flip
them around and forward reverse
and once you build up a model i've got a
new model for
you know traffic in new york city now
that's non-rem now maybe i
i give that model a test run this might
be what rem
is involved so now i have a whole bunch
of these memory
lego block models that i've put together
and now as i start to move through them
trying to figure out well
should i actually have perhaps one model
do i need two so moving through these
memory models during rem
might confer upon them this kind of
bizarre confabulatory like content or
structure
because it's not just about revisiting
memory or experience
what i've just done it's not just about
you know revisiting older memories
but it's putting them together moving
through
these models that have been built on
memory in ways
that attempt to figure out how things
are connected
one thing about you know in ram
different another difference between
non-rem and rem
sleep states memory and these
associations
some studies have been done looking at
your tendency to connect
unrelated things during
when when when people are awakened
during ram or non-rem
if you're awakened during rem sleep you
are far more likely
to be to make novel associations to
connect
things together for instance just given
simple wordless you're far more likely
to connect things that were not really
related
during rem sleep than you are during
non-rem and non-rem
it's pretty much you know the way i you
know the way i saw it is the way i
remember it
so let me so this is a great opportunity
to jump
into carlos's work so you're looking you
you started your career a lot of your
research looking at rem
sleep gone really wrong tell us about
rem sleep behavior disorder well as i've
written in my
blog for the world science festival and
also in my books
my entire career practicing sleep
medicine has been involved with extreme
sleep which are the parasomnias defined
as the abnormal behaviors and
experiences that accompany sleep
and really the parasomnias involved
mixed states of sleep and wakefulness
which are very hazardous experiences
because if you're interacting with the
actual environment
with a lot of your brain still asleep
you're really setting yourself up
to injuring yourself or anyone in your
vicinity
so also with the parasomnias our basic
instincts can be released and
i'm talking about all our basic
instincts sexual behavior
feeding behavior aggression violence
exploration
locomotion everything we can do in our
waking lives can become
unleashed in a very inappropriate way
during our sleep
so on september 11 1982 when i started
my
practice of sleep medicine the second
patient i saw was a gentleman from
golden valley minnesota named donald
dorff
and don complained of violent moving
nightmares
which is a beautiful description of rem
sleep behavior disorder
for several several years he was acting
out dreams that were very different from
his previous dreams
during his rbd dreams he was being
confronted by unfamiliar people or even
animals and he had to respond by hitting
back uh
or becoming very aggressive to protect
himself or his wife
he would also have sports streams that
were very aggressive and in fact the
dream that he had that
led to his coming to see me was a dream
involving american football he was a
half back carrying the ball through the
line of scrimmage
and he lowered his shoulder to uh really
anticipate an impact with a 280 pound
lineman
and when he came to he had actually
lowered his shoulder into the dresser
on the far side of his bedroom and his
head hit the wall and he gashed himself
and really needed a lot of stitches
after all the blood had spilled on the
ground
he had no medical disorder no
psychiatric disorder
he had never been a sleepwalker earlier
in his life so this is the first type of
parasomnia he had experienced
five nights later i decided to go to the
sleep lab
to be with the sleep technologist when
we we monitored him in the sleep lab
and we saw something that was really
unprecedented that during rapid eye
movement sleep instead of displaying the
usual mammalian paralysis
which protects people and other mammals
from acting out their dreams
don had lost that paralysis and he had
muscle tone muscle twitching
and during each of his four rem sleep
episodes he actually was twitching
jerking around throwing punches kicking
talking shouting swearing
and when we entered the room after each
of these events he reported immediately
a dream
and the action in the dream matched what
we had seen so there's a beautiful
correspondence between
the dream activity that he was acting
out and the behaviors that we observed
and that was really the beginning of our
identification of rem sleep behavior
disorder known as rbd
now fortunately we were able to come out
with a medication
through trial and error to calm him down
and what was interesting is that
the medication clonazepam which is a
potent benzodiazepine anti-convulsant
that medication not only stopped the
behaviors of rbd
but it restored normal dreams and so
that has really piqued the interest of
dream researchers because rbd is a dream
disorder
almost as much as a behavior disorder of
sleep so in terms of conceptualizing
dream generation
rbd is a really fertile area for
research
and so with don his bad dreams had gone
away
along with the bad behaviors and he was
a very happy camper
to play golf in his retirement now as we
started seeing more and more of these
patients and
they were being reported around the
world after a certain number of years
years we realized that a lot of these
men with run behavior disorder
developed parkinson's disease which is a
classic neurologic disorder
involving a resting tremor muscle
rigidity
uh slowed down movements called
bradykinesia and also a poor stability
of your posture
so they're really well-defined signs and
symptoms of parkinson's disease
which involves a depletion of dopamine
cells in the brain stem area called the
substantia [ __ ]
now we reported in the journal neurology
in 1996 that 38
of the men with rem behavior disorder
eventually converted to parkinson's
disease
and nothing else now we're up to 81
percent conversion from
rem behavior disorder parkinson's
disease and centers from around the
world are reporting that at least
two-thirds of their patients convert
so really this is actually an important
development in neuroscience and
neurology
in terms of early intervention of people
at risk for future parkinson's disease
and so this has launched really a major
international effort
in terms of identifying rem sleep
behavior disorder patients
and trying to develop trials of what's
called neural protective agents to delay
greatly or even prevent the future
emergence of parkinson's disease
i should also point out that all this
makes scientific sense because
the cells in the brain stem related to
parkinson's disease
interact very very closely with the
cells in the brain involved with
muscle activity and the paralysis
activity
of rem sleep so a lesion that interrupts
the paralysis
activity in rem sleep is a lesion that
also can produce parkinson's disease
it's just a matter of
exactly where that initial lesion is and
you either get rem behavior disorder
first and maybe a decade or two later
parkinson's disease
or you get parkinson's disease first and
later run behavior disorder or you get
both together
so i think that that was a major kind of
scientific revelation about rbd
the good news for us is that we
identified a therapy that helped control
these poor people hurting themselves and
their wives
and also restored normal dreams
i think we should show the image of mel
abel or really a most famous patient
who almost killed his wife now uh male
was just the nicest guy in the world
he had a dream one night and this is how
he had he slept for five years before he
came to see us this is a home remedy
he had a belt around his waist he had a
rope tethered
around his belt attached to the bed post
this is his way of preventing himself
from flying out of bed and running into
the wall
however it did not prevent him from
hurting his wife harriet
so one night he had a dream going back
to his childhood days in spooner
wisconsin
he was with his grandfather they were
pitching hay and they saw two deer
running by them
and uh and then the deer disappeared and
then suddenly
a doe reappeared and mel smashed the doe
with his pitchfork and it stunned a deer
that was blathering
and he decided to put that poor deer out
of its misery
so in his dream he grabbed the deer's
chin with one hand and the top of the
deer's head was the other was about to
snap
its neck when harry is screaming woke
mel up
and fortunately he stopped the process
of almost snapping harriet's neck
well obviously he was extremely
distressed and so was harriet by this
that
you know it's uh clear that in fact the
stern magazine wrote an article 1988
called hunting deer under the blanket
and the new york times sunday magazine
in 2003 called it the man who mistook
his wife for a deer
so extremely dangerous and
life-threatening behaviors can occur
with rbd the good news is that we can
treat it
the disturbing news is that it can lead
to parkinson's disease but the hopeful
news
is that it can lead to early
intervention to prevent the progression
of parkinson's disease because the
parkinson's researchers for decades have
been looking
for the earliest marker of parkinson's
and rbd
is it so it's generated a tremendous
amount of interest
in the parkinson's disease research
community and we now have an
international
remedy behavior disorder research group
and it's truly international four
continents are involved
the researchers and so we're really
trying to help the parkinson's
researchers
besides understanding more about the
brain during sleep
i think we can go to the video now and i
can show you some examples of rbd and
other parasomnias
so this is from our sleep center uh
these men who are typically 50 years old
and older we don't know why this is a
male predominant disorder by the way
that's a big mystery
but this is what they do and if you're
sleeping by him
as this man's wife you know these men
generally wake up feeling rested in the
morning the wives are wiped out
completely wiped out and the husbands
say why are you so tired didn't you
sleep well like me and they said what do
you mean
look what you did so these men they
remember their dreams but they don't
know that they were acting them out and
they feel
rested in the morning so i'm going to
show this again so imagine if you're the
wife
sleeping night after night and these
episodes occur
four or five nights a week so you treat
the man with this clonazepam and it's
like giving the wife a sleeping pill as
well because she sleeps like a baby
after his sleep is under control but a
lot of these patients come to us saying
we want to be believed we want to be
validated people think we're
exaggerating
and in fact they're not and the video
really is proof that there's no
exaggeration here
so let's go to the next video this is a
culture-specific dream in acting
behavior from japan
my colleague uh nana tachibana in osaka
apparently in japan once a couple has a
child
the uh the the wife leaves a bedroom
with the child the husband sleeps alone
and rem behavior disorder is detected uh
basically by
yelling and screaming so this man had a
dream he set up a home video
and he's the samurai warrior acting out
a samurai warrior dream maybe we can
show that one again uh
please so here he is and and he only set
up the video
because he did not believe his wife and
he said all right let's let's set it up
and here's the proof
and in fact he had to believe that his
wife was telling the truth
now how long will he be doing this will
he
go at this all night long well he killed
the enemy so he doesn't have to do it
again
right what's the point
he did it enough to disturb his wife uh
so let's shift gears to another
parasomnia now
and uh this is sleepwalking
so this is from delta non-rem sleep the
deepest stage of sleep the brain waves
are the slowest
we should show this again if we could so
out of the steepest stage of sleep when
we have no clue about our environment
our locomotor system gets activated our
legs start moving we start
standing and walking without any actual
awareness of the environment and you can
see how dangerous it is
there she is sandy in our sleep lab
about to fall out of the bed her legs
are moving but she has no idea why and
it's so inappropriate
i should give an anecdote of a patient
of mine named jan
who was a sleepwalker as long as she was
walking in her life that's how she
described it
so after her divorce her nine-year-old
daughter slept in the same room as jan
and uh so in preparation for sleep at
night the
the shades were drawn completely but
then the daughter was horrified a few
hours later the mother
jan had raised the the blinds halfway
was looking out the window now across
the street from their home was a
cemetery
jan was carrying on a conversation with
the dead people in the cemetery
asking them who's feeding you what are
they feeding you
do do you feel lonely and there was a
pause between the questions and the
daughter realized
she was engaging in a conversation with
the dead people in the cemetery in her
own mind
she asked her mother at the time are you
awake and and jan in very glazed way
said yes well the daughter was so
horrified by this that she never slept
and say move the mother again
and in fact it even mentioned this until
she was a teenager and my patient of
course felt very very badly but
that tells you how you don't have
judgment you don't have the monitor
uh going in terms of your activity while
you're sleepwalking you're engaging
yourself in sleepwalking behaviors with
the environment but you don't have any
awareness you don't really
realize how inappropriate you are we can
go to the next video now
these are two patients would be scary
this is very scary
[Music]
so are these night terrors they seem
like nary terrors the first
was a woman in her early 30s second as a
young girl five years old
screaming at night very loudly however
these occurred multiple times
every single night night terrors even in
children
who are really most likely to have night
terrors maybe once a week once a month
but to have multiple episodes every
night tells you something else is going
on
and these are nocturnal epileptic
seizures uh known as the great mimicker
so if you have
screaming at night and thrashing around
they could be night terrors but the
history of having multiple episodes
every single night
really tips the balance towards
epileptic seizures and in fact the brain
wave activity and both
the woman and the young girl gave good
evidence that there was epileptic
activity going on and they needed
anti-convulsant medication
rather than a clonazepam which is a
benzodiazepine medication
we can go to the next video if we could
now this is a completely different
parasomnia we're going to show this a
second time
this is a 23 year old woman who had been
sexually abused during childhood by an
older sister
and if you look at her shoulders and
we'll show it again the shoulders seem
to be pinned down
while there's a lot of pelvic movement
and this really reflects muscle memory
going over
two decades of the sister pinning her
down
on her shoulders to prevent this poor
young girl from running away
while there's genital stimulation going
on and here we are
talking two decades later and she's
recreating the abuse
scenario of the shoulders being pinned
down and the pelvic stimulation
and this is a really a very disturbed
kind of
poor young woman who needs specialized
psychiatric care but
it's in the realm of parasomnias but
it's a psychiatric parasomnia
okay we can go to the next video
this is a lady who engages in sleep
related eating disorder but
please focus on her pinky because her
pinky does something very peculiar every
time she takes a bite out of her brownie
first of all the pinky is spread out
from the other fingers which is unusual
in itself
but she seems to be nibbling at her
pinky and doing
funny things when she saw this video she
said i never eat that way when i'm awake
never but with each bite of the brownie
let's show her again if we could so we
uh we call this sleep state dependent
uh behavior activation so specific to
the sleep state
and it really indicates that this is not
normal wakeful eating
so she takes the bite of the brownie and
there goes the pinky
so you know this is not someone who's
fully with it in a wakeful
mental mode whatsoever this comes out of
intermediate non-rem sleep called stage
two sleep
and this is typical of sleep-related
eating disorder most patients have
episodes every single night
and they gain weight and they feel very
much out of sorts from this eating
behavior
and this is called a final common
pathway disorder
that can be accessed through sleep apnea
restless leg syndrome
medications like sleeping pills or it
can just run in the family
and be a variation of sleepwalking but
once it becomes well established
it usually occurs every single night and
with a lot of metabolic consequences
obesity consequences
and sleep disruption consequences and
this is one of the tougher parasomnias
to treat
although about two-thirds of the treated
patients do respond very well to the
therapy
but you have to know what the underlying
or associated sleep condition is
like sleep apnea restless leg syndrome
to identify the most effective therapy
but
you already got a glimpse of how our
basic instincts can be released
inappropriately during sleep
later on i will describe a very dramatic
case that made canadian legal history
involving sleepwalking and murder
and i will also describe sexsomnia but i
think we need to move on
uh yeah so thank you for that now now in
terms of extreme
sleep um you know we might have a sort
of a little uh contest going here you've
got extreme human sleep but i think
neil's
is got some extreme animal sleep uh
that uh it's it's pretty amazing i mean
just in terms of
like uh why don't you just tell people
about
the these birds particular birds you've
been starting to study like in the wild
yeah so uh recent technological
advancements
uh in microchip technology developed by
a colleague in the university of zurich
alex uh
alexi vysatsky has allowed us to
actually
record brain activity and sleep related
brain activity
in animals in the wild and this is
important for two reasons
one we did the first study of an animal
sleeping in a
in the wild in this case it was a sloth
and we found that
sloths are not so slothful after all
people previously thought they slept 16
hours a day
some people said 20 hours a day but when
we recorded their brain activity in the
wild we found they only slept
nine and a half hours a day over six
hours less than
captive sloths so that finding in and of
itself is important because it calls
into question
you know the the nature of sleep that
we're recording
in captivity or in in the laboratory at
least in terms of how long an animal is
there might not be too much to do in the
lab
so yeah mine i guess we don't exactly
know the reason for the
this difference and i think it can even
go the other way that some animals
uh might be particularly fearful in the
laboratory and sleep less than they do
in the wild
but it could be differences and they
don't have to forage they don't have
some animals may feel safe in the lab
and some may
feel threatened so i think it can go in
each direction
but but to study things in the wild i
mean you have to take all this equipment
that you
it's easy to use in the lab and you've
got to take it outside and
to some pretty extreme places yeah it it
it is
tricky um our our laboratory becomes
a tent on a remote island or
the back of a pickup truck in in the
the rain forest in panama um but the
birds that we're really interested in
studying now do some extraordinary
things
there are several species that you'll
see in this
image that engage in
periods of continuous activity lasting
days weeks months maybe even longer
there's a bird in the upper left corner
the bartail
godwit it's been shown that they fly
non-stop for eight days
from alaska to new zealand where they
spend the winter
and we actually have a map i believe
yeah and there
take a look at that map and this is
showing a
a gps track they put a device on these
spurs that could tell
exactly where they were and you can see
uh
alaska up on the top of the globe and
they start there and they fly all the
way to new zealand without stopping at
all
and then they make comparable long
flights on the way back
going via china in this case um
so this raises the question well how do
they get their
sleep and every other animal sleep seems
to be a daily phenomena and very
important as
as as we all know and as i know being
quite jet-lagged today you're doing
great
um what happens if you try to keep a
bird awake for a long time
i mean does it just say please leave me
alone i need sleep i mean
yeah and we've actually recently shown
with
pigeons that if you uh take away just
their normal daytime napping
uh that they become very sleepy and when
we
let them sleep and record their brain
activity they
they sleep much more deeply so the
brainwave patterns respond just like
they do in humans
and also we've shown that if you
stimulate
one part of the brain in this case we we
had birds watch
david attenborough's the life of birds
on tv
uh with just one eye
oh that's not fair we just
covered one eye and showed them the show
and uh
the part of the brain connected to that
eye that watched the tv slept much more
deeply so just like i had mentioned in
humans the sleep
seems to be regulated in the bird brain
depending on how different regions were
used
so sleep is clearly important for birds
they need to recover and their
brain responds the same way ours does
but then if we can go back
the uh the in addition to this bird the
bartender
godwit um there are other birds that
engage in
in uh long flights the
the frigate bird on the top right um
they go to sea to feed for several days
lasting periods up to 12 days
but surprisingly for a sea bird
frigate birds cannot land on the water
if they do
they get wet and they can't take off and
they drown and that's it
um and so they go to out to sea foraging
for
days or weeks and can't sit on the water
so
then again the question of do they sleep
there also unlike our swifts here the
european swift is
is renowned for engaging in long flights
it's thought that other than the time
when they're actually taking care of the
nestlings
that these swifts are flying
continuously
it's even been shown they put that
on their first night out the first night
they leave the nest
first time they've ever flown they they
actually go up into the sky and spend
the night
soaring up in the night sky with all the
adult birds
and it's thought that from that point on
they may not land
until they nest two or three years later
and so when do they sleep
and there's also a bird ironically
called the wide awake turn it's
ironic because it's called that because
it's
call sounds like it's saying wide awake
wide awake
um it's not because scientists have
actually shown that it's wide awake but
maybe it's telling us something these
birds they give you lots of clues
um they're like the frigate birds they
go out to sea
but they can't sit on the water they'll
get wet
and drown so again when did they sleep
and finally a bird that i'm flying to
alaska to
study tomorrow morning at
4 00 am is
uh the one in the lower left the
pectoral sandpiper
and this bird doesn't engage in long
non-stop flights
but we have some reason to believe that
they engage in periods of constant
activity during the breeding season
colleagues at our institute have shown
that they're
active for two to three weeks
continuously
around the clock 24 7. and
in this case they seem to be doing it to
get
mates these the male shown here
he stays awake and he chases all the
other males away from his females and
guards his territory whereas
uh the females they seem to sleep like
other birds for several hours a night
so um we suspect that they're not
sleeping but we want to
confirm this by recording their brain
activity
so you're going to be you you've
developed
equipment where you can do this where
you can actually
yeah working with colleagues that
develop the microchip technology we can
record their brain activity
and we've actually tested it on these
birds a couple years ago so
that it's all ready to go and we just
need to collect the data and
i think you know on the one hand if bert
some of these birds are sleeping in
flight
that's fascinating and maybe they're
sleeping with one half of the brain at a
time
but it's these birds that might also
engage in extended periods of not
sleeping that might be the really
exciting ones because
again it would just challenge what we
know and think about
sleep in general as being so important
and it would raise the question well
how are they doing it what is going on
in their brains that allow them to
suspend
sleep for this long period of time
and if we can learn how they're doing
this
that might tell us something about the
purpose of sleep in general
so we're not just studying these because
they're cool and interesting animals but
they might actually tell us something
important about what sleep is doing for
our brain
so we have a little time left but carlos
i
you've talked about murder and sex
and we cannot let you leave before you
satisfy what i do for a living yeah well
i deal with
out of control eating sex and aggression
i get paid for it and i do a video and i
don't get arrested for it either you
know
so nice work if you can get it so we can
show the image of kenneth parks uh
kenneth james parks age 24 six foot five
inches tall
280 pounds on the night of may 24th 1987
he was sitting in front of his tv in the
living room had fallen asleep he woke up
put on his shoes grabbed the set of car
keys
left the house leaving the front door uh
completely wide open
got in his car left leaving the garage
door completely open
he drove through the streets of toronto
23 kilometers which is 14 miles
went to the home of his in-laws barbara
woods and donald woods
and in the garage he took out a tire
iron went upstairs
uh to their bedroom he nearly strangled
his father-in-law
donald woods uh before he went to his
mother-in-law
barbara woods uh he smashed her with a
tire iron
she had blaine uh brain bleeding but he
stabbed her six times with a kitchen
knife
and the stabbed through the heart killed
her he then
went uh to the door outside the door
the two doors of their teenage daughters
and they reported later that he was
grunting in a very loud way like an
animal
and it was terrifying because then he
stopped grunting and he started again
fortunately he did not he did not enter
their room
he left the home walked into a police
station at 4 45 in the morning and he
said
i think i killed somebody i don't know
what happened
i saw the face of barbara woods it
looked very sad to me
but i don't know what happened i think i
did something terrible
the police made a very important
observation he had cut the tendons of
all his fingers
the flexor tendons in the process of
stabbing his mother-in-law and his
father-in-law
the kitchen knife must have slipped
through his fingers and he cut the
flexor tendons he showed no pain he felt
no pain
and in the subsequent trial that was
very important evidence to indicate that
he was not really with it not
awake because people if they're awake
will have incredible pain after cutting
basically 10 tendons of your hands now
he was acquitted
in the trial that began a year later and
this made canadian legal history the
first time
the sleepwalking defense was
successfully used in a murder case
now people will say how could this be
well the
the evidence was really compelling i
reviewed the 1700
court transcript which i analyzed in my
book paradox lost
and basically i think the jury got it
right first of all he had a sleepwalking
history at the age of 11
his mother caught him as he was about to
leave the sixth floor window of their
dwelling i mean he would have killed
himself
he was always known to be a very very
deep sleeper he also had an incredible
family history of sleepwalking
20 first-degree and second-degree family
relatives
had parasomnias i mean it's just
unbelievable uh
and covering four different parasomnias
sleepwalking sleep terror sleep
uh talking and also sleep related eating
disorders so he had the
incredible family history he had the
personal history
and on top of that he had three major
precipitating factors for people
with a vulnerability to sleepwalking the
first uh
the first factor was that he had been
sleep deprived 48 hours
which is a known risk factor for
sleepwalkers second of all
he had major physical stress he had
played rugby
on a very hot and humid afternoon in
toronto and he was incredibly out of
shape
so that's what we call a physical stress
and third he had emotional stress
he had been a gambler had gotten into
major debt
and that was really weighing on him and
really having an adverse effect on their
marriage
also in the kind of witch's brew of his
sleepwalking mind
the next day he had organized a picnic
a barbecue at his in-laws house so in
the sleepwalking mine he was driving to
his in-laws
he just happened to do it maybe 12 hours
too soon
in the wrong state of mind in other
words the sleepwalking mine
how the violence and the murder entered
in we don't know
but basically he had no motivation to
kill his in-laws and in fact
when he first met his future wife karen
she was a teenage runaway
and he convinced her to go back to her
parents so that her in-laws
were immensely appreciative of him
because
he helped rescue their runaway daughter
told her go back to your parents he
eventually married them
and they considered him like a son in
fact barbara woods called him
my gentle giant and in fact he murdered
her so there was really no reason at all
for motive for murder he had been a
sleepwalker he had the risk factors for
that night
and he had the family history and for
that reason the the jury i think got it
right by acquitting him
the prosecution in canada can appeal a
murder trial unlike the united states
and on appeal the acquittal was was
sustained it was basically supported
and uh and unfortunately i heard that
down the road he
eventually did get divorced i think it
was just too much of a strain on
your marriage when your wife realizes
you killed my mother you almost killed
my father
although apparently he did well with
clonazepam as therapy of his
sleepwalking but
i think this is an extreme example of
sleepwalking but it's unintentional
behavior with tragic
tragic consequences and obviously
sleepwalkers should
avoid their precipitating factors in
terms of sleep deprivation
physical stress and deal with their
emotional stress the best way possible
let me conclude of my section by talking
about sexsomnia
now in relation to rbd run behavior
disorder i think sigmund freud would
have been very disappointed
he would have said my god what a great
opportunity for sexual acting out
you're dreaming in rem sleep you don't
have the paralysis
you know let the games begin but the
reality is
there is no sexual acting out without
behavior disorder in fact there's a bias
against sexual dreams there's a bias for
aggressive dreams
locomotion dreams sports dreams but
there's a bias
against sexual dreams and this has been
demonstrated in a very nice controlled
study from italy
but with sex omnia actually is though
during non-rem sleep when there is no
dreaming
and it really covers the whole gamut of
sexuality in terms of sleep sex
talking masturbation sexual assault
including rape including other legal
cases
involving children and adults and this
is appears to be a male predominant
disorder although we really don't know
for sure
it's just that the women complain about
the men engaging in sex omni and they're
the ones who come for help
the men generally don't complain about
their partners and
this is really a sociological question i
would say much more than a medical
question and
uh you know years ago the kinsey report
kind of had a golden opportunity but
it did not address any issue of sexual
behaviors during sleep just sexual
dreams but
uh sexsomnia also known as sleep sex
can really be associated either with a
long history
of sleepwalking night terror sleep
related eating in other words
it comes at the end of a long history of
non-rapid eye movement sleep parasomnias
or it's associated with sleep apnea
people snore
and it's called snorgasm by the way
among you know we believe in really
precise
terminology we have sex apnea and orgasm
uh but you have snoring and sexual
behavior and for the bed partner
the snoring is just as disconcerting as
a sexual behavior saying my god
having sex when your partner is snoring
what is going on here
but it really reflects what's called a
confusional arousal when you snore you
have a partial awakening again
a mixed state of sleep and wakefulness
with very inappropriate behaviors
so during this mixed state induced by
the sleep apnea you can engage in eating
behavior aggressive behavior or a sexual
behavior
so the typical scenario for sex omnia is
either a long history
of other parasomnias or a relatively
recent history of sex omnia with sleep
apnea
and the good news like with most of the
parasomnias they can be
effectively treated after being properly
diagnosed
so i think with sex omnia there's a very
dramatic parasomnia but it fits in with
the whole realm
of other parasomnias and the release of
instinctual behaviors
but the field of sleep medicine can
diagnose patients
and treat effectively most of the
patients and for me as a physician
this has been the most gratifying part
besides all the discoveries it's really
treating patients making them happy
making their bed partners happy
allowing them to live during the daytime
without any adverse consequences from
sleep gone bad so
just in order to wrap things up let's
kind of look to the future
how about each of you take a minute to
do just to tell me
what question do you want to know the
answer to about sleep what is
what is the burning question that you
would really love
to know let's start with you nielsen
can i sleep on it
i don't know um there
you know we've talked about rem sleep
and we focused on the brain wave
patterns and what characterizes them but
there are other aspects of rem sleep
that occur again both in mammals and in
birds
that don't get much attention one of
them is
for some unclear reason during rem sleep
we stop thermoregulating birds who are
hot while they're sleeping will pant
during non-rem sleep but when they enter
rem sleep they stop
similar things happen in in mammals so
what is the purpose of this aspect of
rem sleep has
is not getting much attention
so what about you matt well i think that
you know the the fundamental question
it's the question of
you know how do we learn how do we you
know how do we build these models of the
world
how do we uh so you see sleeping as
learning
sleeping is learning in fact you know
you know just listening to the you know
these uh you know other presentations
that
really focused on behaviors that can
occur during certain kinds of dream
sleep
non-rem sleep and i was you know making
the connection between
quiet wakefulness and sort of thinking
and non-rem dreaming
and i realized it was important to point
out that there's this
there's this kind of connection that
we've made between sleeping and
particularly non-rem sleep and
inactivity now during thinking when
you're sitting and thinking
it turns out even in you know in animals
they can think perfectly well
when they're doing sitting quietly doing
nothing or
engaged in automatic behaviors don't
require attention that include
eating having sex turns out that's
you know their minds can wander when
they have sex as well
so it's when so that that there's this
state that involves
thinking why you can still engage in
auto automatic behavior
that can include things like driving
there are systems in the brain
that are built to take over automatic
behavior and when we're not doing that
we can be thinking about other things
non-rem sleep may carry all of the same
baggage along with it the ability
to do things while you are
thinking about other things so it's this
connection between
thinking sleeping dreaming
and learning and so the question a
burning question i have is
impossible to show that what we dream
influences what we do not the other way
around which is the way we tend to think
about it we
dream about what we remember well is it
possible that what we dream about
actually changes
how we learn how we behave and there are
these interesting connections between
memory
the areas of the brain involved in
memory and imagination our ability
to remember the past is linked to our
ability to
imagine the future so you can think of
dreams as a way i mean i don't know what
kind of future you imagine with your
crazy cacti
but you can think of dreams in a way
they are a process a process of
imagining
a world and perhaps anticipating a world
in which we are going to have
to interact with and so the connection
between
not just memory not just learning
but creativity imagination all these
things
that we believe define what we are as
uniquely sentient intelligent beings so
it's deeply embedded in my sense that
that sleep is revealing something
about what makes us unique and
intelligent
i would echo what matt was talking about
that i'm very curious about all the
benefits
of sleep on our waking lives because we
know that disturbed sleep has adverse
effects in our waking lives
so i i'm really curious about the whole
range the whole panorama
of the benefits of good sleep on our
waking lives so we can enhance it
quite honestly and and if in fact there
are creatures out there that don't
really
need sleep what is it about their
wakefulness that is so
intrinsically good for them that they
don't need sleep
so i think that's an open question as
well great well
let's give a hand to our panelists and
wish them a good night's sleep
[Music]
you